we have to learn a lot more about the
earth and about the system that we live
in before we can be sure of offsetting
the bad effects of global warming nor
more measurements more investigation and
particularly long records not showing
the change over time this is the thing
we are lacking we don't have what was
happening in the ocean shall we say ten
years ago I think it's quite deplorable
that we know more about the surface of
Mars than we do about the bottom of her
own sea well I've long sought and argued
in favor of nuclear energy I think it's
had a very bad press indeed it's nowhere
near as dangerous as it's made out to be
indeed when you look at the figures it's
the safest fuel you can have by a long
long measure and but people have pushed
hard to use renewable energy windmills
and solar and so on and there's
something to be said for them in certain
places if in fact it's been worked out
that if you could have several hundred
square miles of Sahara with nothing but
solar panels you could provide power for
the whole of Europe that way but it's
politics yes people with religious
persuasions of all to blow it up that
that would succeed probably I don't well
how can I put it entertainment is
terribly important as
your firm must know and it's most
entertaining to have people go to the
moon I never I shall not forget the
excitement that was with the Apollo
mission and I was partly involved in it
I think I was the first person in this
country to be asked by NASA to provide
equipment for the Apollo mission no I
don't think it's practical as things
stand at the moment it would not be safe
to travel to Mars the radiation from the
Sun and from space generally is so great
well it makes the danger of nuclear
energy quite trivial and it's
questionable about whether the
astronauts would survive a journey to
Mars and back oh I think we it's been
looked at the wrong way around that they
we look at artificial isn't intelligence
as something that our scientists have
made or our engineers have made
scientists usually I'll show now don't
make much they'd explain things
it's engineers that make things that
they care very little credit but that we
haven't really got terribly far now
don't think that artificial intelligence
man-made is going to do much but what we
forgotten is Darwin things evolve and
there is the potential in artificial
intelligence so start evolving itself
after all most of the parts inside the
telephone you carry in your pocket
they're not man-made they're made by
machines themselves and it won't be long
before they start to plan them according
to their own design a lot according to
ours
and then of course evolution sets in and
it's a different world altogether no the
very reverse we are as needed we should
look really at the new life the
artificial life that evolves in the same
way as we look at plants there they are
they're only different from us in their
speed plants were about 10,000 times
slower than we are
that's why farmer Jobs can look across
the than watch his crops rotate and it's
the same kind of thing they would be ten
thousand times faster at least than real
in thinking and doing everything and
time would cost ten thousand times
slower so that that a year for them
would be like centuries for us the
theory is that the earth ever since is
beginning has evolved by itself in other
words if things grew too hot on the
earth systems would evolve that cooled
it and that and that has been the case
it's quite remarkable you see the Sun
has warmed up something that's 30
percent since life again on the earth
but if the temperature had risen that
much we wouldn't be here to talk about
it yes has regulated itself when
controlling the amount of carbon dioxide
and me saying and there's a greenhouse
gases in the air purely biologically and
kept he kept a constancy
so that everything was happy we've
reached a point now where the Sun is now
so hot that it's very difficult for the
whole system to do it and when we start
interfering and adding fossil fuels to
there it becomes double
hard to keep the earth right but we've
got to do it if we're going to survive
our scene well III hope we work it out
somehow
I think there is a chance if we get get
things right but we are a dodgy lot well
strangely I was on a BBC program with
him long ago
or it was a book review program and
involved one of my own books and I got
on quite well with voice I thought he
was so uh as far as I'm concerned yes
give him a whirl
see what happens